this is what I hear okay that there's a
difference between our Kelly the
Entertainer and Robert Kelly the man you
know where I'm going with that oh no I
don't know where you're going
this is charming and likable what is
very controlling and abusive that's
right there like that are there two are
Kelly's there's a Robert and there's a
are Kelly like what dr. Jekyll and mr.
Hyde all right we'll go with that but
absolutely with that but absolutely not
okay Robert is the guy who sings his
singing name is are Kelly it's
equivalent to a policeman yes when a
policeman put on his badge and his suit
in his uniform
he'd go out to do his job when he take
that unit when he on that job he's a
beast he's tough he has to be he's got
to be in control he's got to be not out
of control you got to do his work when
he takes that off and gets home he's
with his family he loves his family and
if he's single
he made mingle but however he still is
here he's still here to serve and
protect at the time he's told to do it
I'm r.kelly
most age okay but that's Robert in a
r.kelly uniform